this morning we are learning about a
momentous discovery that could overturn
our understanding of human history the
discovery was made by researchers
studying our pre-human ancestors in an
area of South Africa known as the Cradle
of humankind they now believe those
ancestors may have had a head start in
using fire as a tool Deborah patta shows
us why that is so important
sometimes you just have to go upside
down and turn around to see what's been
right in front of you all along you know
make it look simple
that's renowned paleoanthropologist Lee
Berger talking to an orange clad team
member hanging upside down in the rising
star caves just outside Johannesburg
dubbed underground astronauts they've
made a profound Discovery we're in the
tunnel
turns out humans are not so special
after all just because we've been by it
a hundred times
doesn't mean we've seen it
nearly 10 years ago burger and his team
first discovered a new species here homo
naledi one of our non-human ancestors
great work beautiful Hebrew sharp
criticism for hypothesizing that the
creature was deliberately placing its
dead in a dark and dangerous underground
chamber that no one believed was
possible to navigate without light and
the reason they didn't believe it was
because
I'm on the lady with its tiny little
brain just bigger than a chimpanzee
couldn't have had fire the controlled
use of fire was supposedly unique to
humans and for nearly a decade his team
found no evidence homo naledi had used
fire well done guys until Burger lost
over 50 pounds so that he could squeeze
through those narrow corridors himself
for the very first time in August
it was torture all the way down into the
first time exhausted he finally reached
the bottom and I looked up
and I realized the ceiling was black
it was burnt it was covered in soot it
had been right above our heads the
entire time but you were looking down
all the time we're always looking down
undeniable evidence of fire on that very
same day his lead investigator
paleoanthropologist kenilwe monopiani
was making another remarkable find
nearby and then pieces of bonus are
coming up burnt bone and I'm just like
okay
are I can't ignored anymore right
because as an archaeologist you have to
follow the evidence burnt balance
they were eating there
after that they saw fire everywhere and
I suspect based on what we're seeing
they're not just carrying fire
I think they're making it the
manufacturer the manufacturing farm and
it's done hundreds of thousands of years
perhaps before maybe humans were doing
booger believes that this discovery will
challenge our assumptions about human
uniqueness and it should give us pause
to make us think deeply about the way we
have placed ourselves on a pedestal
something special
because home and letters began to prove
that it may have happened many times in
the past we are arrogant as humans
though because we think we have we're
Superior I mean one of the reasons that
humans are so
harmful to the environment to this world
is because we think we have some
ownership of it
it's not just about a groundbreaking
discovery for a very long time
um
anthropology all those discoveries made
in Africa have been made by men
yeah that is when we start taking back
the narrative as Africans and we get top
stories now here's mirror and that
narrative starts with the understanding
that we are not just part of a complex
now there has been a complex past as
well
we just never saw it because all this
time we've been looking down
instead of looking up for CBS mornings
Deborah Patrick cradle of humankind
South Africa
what a fascinating story it's a
mind-blowing story that scientists who
lost 50 pounds so he could get down into
that little cave and then he looks up
and he sees it there's fire evidence on
the ceiling to understand but that's
dedication dedication whatever motivates
you right yes yes just to understand
human evolution to understand that as we
all originated from this cradle of
civilization in Africa uh from the very
first proto-human Australopithecus
zapharensis to these new discoveries
that they're finding is remarkable okay
Mr scientist over there what was that
wordensis is one of the did you see how
that just floated there was Africanus
there was and then of course we get into
the omorectus Homo habilis Tony I really
hope your daughter what did you say
you're speaking English Latin
I mean I'm an anthropology nerd amongst
the nerding of other things Edwards here
in yet another page in the book of life
I know